welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moon knight episode three took
us to egypt and upped its illusion game
from suggesting a third hidden altar
more willing to take a stab at stabbing
and konshu won't be in the star map to
confuse us all like that sleep demon who
moves the tack gum glow in the dark
stars in my bedroom ceiling he goes by
another name but it's not that messiah
i'm discussing today but another already
confirmed mcu villain who i speculated
might tie into this moon night series
and uh actually in an easter egg you
might have missed in episode three
finally showed his face folks pharaoh
rahmatut aka kang the conqueror 100
appeared in episode three of moon knight
and we were all too busy staring
directly at solar eclipses to notice i
mean seriously arnie why were you
looking directly at it did you learn
astronomy from the same tutor who taught
you mandarin hey a reminder that the
best way to support new rockstars is to
check out our wickedly sweet moon night
shirt tomb the moon god limited supply
and running out fast over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
so moon knight episode 3 opens with mark
spector in egypt attempting to track
down arthur harrow and his dig crew
chasing down a contact who ends up
getting killed by these three thugs the
guy credited as young thug is the last
of them standing after mark gets knocked
in the head a few times and blacks out
waking up having just stabbed the other
two a move that steven claims he did not
do implying there was a third altar like
jake lockley who might have crossed that
line and mark while a deadly mercenary
willing to take a life in self-defense
even pulled a punch against this kid and
opted to give him the treatment you give
someone after they made a gi jane joke
oh wow but mark even later pushes back
on konshu to try to spare this kid's
life take him to the ledge
he's just a kid
he'll talk but the only thing this kid
talks about is how he is drinking that
same ahmet kool-aid praise
boom you're looking for ramen too bad
better move the moon but here my friends
is where our easter egg is hidden
because on the back of that jean jacket
worn by that young thug is art of a
pharaoh head with a specifically shaped
headpiece and splashes of the colors
teal and purple those are of course the
colors of kanga conqueror in his pharaoh
ramatat form and the headpiece is
designed directly from mike del mundo's
art of ferrorama tut from avengers vol 7
number 4 in 2017 part of the kang war
storyline the only thing missing from
this art cryptically is kang's actual
face it's a blank space a void which
also tells us something because kang
through his countless variants takes on
many faces and to all the skeptics out
there i hear ya especially you geniuses
at work who share our video thumbnails
on twitter and reddit clearly without
watching the videos you may say this is
just another case of me pointing to
random comic panels to compare disney
plus series episodes and make mountains
out of molehills but uh i can confirm
that we have been in contact with crew
members from moon night who verified
that this was an intentional kang
pharaoh ramatan easter egg on the jacket
people this is real this is legit and i
am losing it because i began speculating
as early as episode 1 that ahmet's
mystery first avatar the one who hero
claimed betrayed it the one whom she had
given that crocodile head staff with the
shred of her power now carried by harrow
that traitor could have been pharaoh
rama tut based on the fact that the kang
variant he remains keeps variant
versions of the pyramids of giza in the
sphinx as collections in his void and
not decaying keeping wonders of the
world as trophies in his kingdom
chronopolis in the comics and using the
sphinx as his initial time machine
vehicle that he used to travel back to
ancient egypt to begin with and really
whoever betrayed ahmet must have been
some promethean figure with the level of
cunning beyond your average ancient
egyptian perhaps a scientist and a timed
lord from the 31st century and
philosophically both he and ahmet apply
the same principle of judging people by
their predestined fates before they
really do anything wrong remember in
loki episode 6 he remains dead hint at
having a history taking several
alternate forms i've been dubbed many
names by many people a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains a jerk but it's
it's not as simple
as a name and to me the likeliest ruler
an mcu past that he remains could have
been referring to there based on his
acquisition of those pyramids in the
sphinx was an ancient egyptian pharaoh
and now this jacket proves that not only
does pharaoh ramitat exist in mcu past
but maybe also since this kid was an
amit worshiper that there could have
been some link between rama tut and
ahmet beyond their philosophical
approaches to justice but hey imagine
this scenario you got a big date or an
important job interview or you're about
to be in front of millions of people
watching you on youtube but wait a
second what's that a huge zit who
invited that to the party well today's
sponsor frontman is here to help you
disinvite your unwelcome acne guest so
frontman fade is a skin colored cream
with proven acne fighting ingredients it
covers acne while treating it it's
dermatologists developed and made with
natural extracts
[Music]
what greasy spot look you'll be looking
better in literally 10 seconds front man
fade won't clog your pores and it's
sweat proof which is good for me because
some of my videos can get pretty intense
it's like i'm running a 10k through
these missable details and am i right so
grab yourself some frontman fade to
cover your acne while treating it head
to
befriendman.com new rockstars who use
the link in the description for 15 off
your order but i will say we have not
got confirmation that ferro rama tut was
on its first avatar per se and indeed
the translations on the hieroglyphics on
that scarab quote a line from the book
of the dead and insert the name
aminotepe as if the scarab could have
been commissioned by one of the three
pharaohs named aminotepe either the
first the second or the third and then
one of them could have been ahmed's
avatar and there are plenty of other
people linked with egyptian history in
the ancient world who could have played
that role so whether or not rama tut aka
kang was amit's avatar this sighting
here confirms that ramadan was at least
a presence in egyptian history in the
mcu and that the moon knight team is
very aware of this shared history now it
is interesting to note that something
spooked the egyptian gods we have not
abandoned humanity
they abandoned us we decided long ago
we did not wish to meddle
in the affairs of man yes unlike the
eternals who continued to walk the earth
to meddle in small ways you know like
keeping fossils from crushing kids
during earthquakes these gods spend
almost all of their time in what konshu
calls the overvoid an otherworldly
astral realm from the marvel comics
originally called the celestial
heliopolis from the thor comics
meanwhile the background of their
chamber in the pyramid seen on either
sides of the entrance that mark arrives
through are dozens of small ushabti
lined up suggesting that as they did
with amit and now they're doing a konchu
these five members of the ine ad encased
countless other egyptian deities in
stone why well let's not forget they are
down to five and in egyptian mythology
the indiana has nine members atom shu
tepnut geb nut osiris isis set and
nephthis and sometimes includes a tenth
member horus we talked about this lineup
with the poster in episode one which
stephen even points out shows only seven
members and we pointed out excludes some
of the main ones but includes horus as
well as hawthor we need hawthorne and
her avatar yup seal in episode three but
hawthor is never ranked in egyptian
mythology as a member of the indiana so
basically it looks like six of the nine
indiana's original members were removed
horus was promoted and then they invited
hawthor so i guess they'd have five
because really yeah every panel of
judges needs an odd number so that
there's a tie-breaking vote but then
most of the other gods were purged into
stone while these five just piece out of
the overvoid so what happened well i
think that abandonment that horace's
avatar referred to was one human who
made them obsolete the way all human
enlightenment and science is a threat to
superstition and religion so someone who
unlocked the secrets of technology so
advanced it rendered his science
inseparable from magic the kind of
science equals magic fusion that only
the asgardian gods had reached that man
being a self-described jerk from the
future who lorded over this historical
era to collect trophies for his case and
now we have physical evidence that that
human being was a ruler named pharaoh
rama tut a person who goes by many names
and we know him best as kang hey a
reminder to check out our moon night
inspired merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you